implica algo que es bastante fácil de
prever o de haber previsto antes del
retiro estados unidos es bastante
pragmático cuando tiene que defender
parte de sus intereses entiende que la
situación de seguridad interna en
afganistán es muy problemática sobre
todo con vistas a la salida de miles de
refugiados fuera del país entiende
también de que los talibanes tienen
algunas diferencias de orden ideológica
con otras organizaciones competitivas y
por tanto solamente le interesa levantar
un emirato en su propia zona territorial
y por esa misma razón forma parte de
focos de esfera de enemistad de otras
organizaciones como el grupo del estado
islámico y sabe también que estas otras
organizaciones tienen como una de sus
metas principales realizar atentados
contra eeuu y sus aliados y por lo tanto
frente a dos escenarios relativamente
negativos la toma de poder de los
talibanes y al mismo tiempo el escenario
de seguridad pero que eeuu está tomando
una decisión pragmática requiere
negociar para incrementar su propia
seguridad para garantizar de que
ciudadanos estadounidenses o bien
ciudadanos que
forman parte de su esfera de influencia
puedan salir de afganistán y lograr
contener a lo que son las organizaciones
que realmente tienen una perspectiva más
internacional en el ámbito del
desarrollo y sus atentados como el
estado islámico
usted nos estaba hablando un poco de la
situación de seguridad en afganistán y
el aumento también de los atentados
suicidas y esto pone en duda la promesa
del talibán de preservar la seguridad en
afganistán que tan importante cree usted
que es esto para la comunidad
internacional
es crucial por dos razones la número uno
es puramente publicitaria o medio
comunicacional en el sentido de que todo
atentado que ocurra dentro de afganistán
más allá de que forme parte de una
lógica en la cual llevamos inserto
durante 20 años va a animar la
perspectiva de que la situación de
inseguridad es mucho peor de lo que
realmente se piensa esto tiene que ver
un poco con la dinámica del terrorismo
el terrorismo es muy espectacular y
tiene este elemento de teatralidad de la
propia violencia del propio propia
terror por lo tanto también hay un
elemento como esto se percibe desde el
punto de vista internacional pero sin
lugar a dudas afganistán forma parte de
un foco de seguridad es muy importante
no solamente porque por afganistán se
produce por ejemplo una parte muy
sustantiva de el mercado de los opioides
sino porque también es foco de atracción
de organizaciones que comparten algún
tipo de relación de orden e ideológica y
en ese sentido tanto para estados unidos
como para la unión europea y algunos de
sus aliados
estabilidad interna de afganistán es
clave independientemente de quién está
tomando el poder señor larsson muchas
gracias por explicarnos este panorama y
la importancia que tiene afganistán en
la seguridad internacional